RIGHT NOU. THIS MEANS
ROSENSTEIN, THE DEPUTY, MAY
HAVE EVEN MORE INFLUENCE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JOINING US FOR MORE REACTION WE
HAVE JOHN SOLOMON A REPORTER
FOR THE HILL NEWSPAPER.
FORMER SECRET SERVICE AGENT DAN
BONGINO AND TALK RADIO HOST AND
ATTORNEY LEO TERRELL.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU, LEO.
WE ALL THOUGHT THAT -- I
THOUGHT AND I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE THOUGHT THE PRESIDENT
MAY HAVE SOME REDACTIONS BUT
ULTIMATELY RELEASE THE MEMO.
IT IS NOT COMING OUT TONIGHT.
HOW ARE YOU AND THE DEMOCRATS
GOING TO REACT TO THAT?
>> WELL, IT’S A SHA. I’LL TELL
YOU WHY.
LAST WEEK, JASON, DESPITE A
PUBLIC ANNOUNCEMENT BY THE
F.B.I. NOT TO RELEASE THE
REPUBLICAN MEMO, PRESIDENT
SHAME ON THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE
IT IS VERY CLEAR HE DID NOT
WANT THIS MEMO RELEASED BECAUSE
IT NEGATES HELPS ARGUMENT.
THERE IS NOTHING IN THE MEMO
PREVENTED ITS RELEASE IT WAS
PAD P.R. FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> DID YOU SEE ANYTHING IN THE
NUNES MEMO THAT WAS -- DEALT
WITH CLASSIFIED MATERIAL ABOUT
SOURCES AND METHODS?
>> I WILL PULL RANK ON
EVERYBODY.
I’M THE LAWYER IN THIS GROUP.
I’LL SIMPLY TELL YOU THIS.
THE F.B.I. SAID DON’T RELEASE
IT.
AND THEY RELEASED IT
NOTWITHSTANDING.
>> THERE WAS NO CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL ABOUT SOURCES AND
METHODS IN THE NUNES MEMO,
CORRECT?
>> THE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PROCEDURE AND MANNER IN WHICH A
WARRANT IS OBTAINED.
THAT INFORMATION SHOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN RELEASED TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC BUT IT WAS
BENEFICIAL TO DONALD TRUMP AND
HE RELEASED IT NOTWITHSTANDING
A PUBLIC STATEMENT FROM THE
F.B.I. AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE NOT TO RELEASE IT.
>> JOHN, LET’S GO TO THIS.
THERE IS ALSO WORD ABOUT A
SECOND DOSSIER THAT IS OUT
THERE.
TELL US WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT
THAT?
>> IN THE SUMMER OF 2016 THERE
WAS ANOTHER PIPELINE OF
CLINTON-RELATED INFORMATION
COMING INTO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AND TO CHRISTOPHER
STEELE AND TO THE F.B.I.
IT COMES THROUGH TWO GUYS THAT
WE’VE HEARD FROM THE PAST IN
THE OLD CLINTON YEARS IN THE
90s.
TONY SHEER, A PRIVATE EYE,
SIDNEY BLUMENTHAL.
THEIR EYE SPY INSIDE THE
CAMPAIGN.
THEY PUT THE INFORMATION IN AND
TRACKS CLOSE TO WHAT STEELE HAD.
ALL THIS INFORMATION COMING IN.
I PREDICT ALL FOUR SOURCES OF
THE INFORMATION THE F.B.I. USED
THE LAUNCH THE INVESTIGATION
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP EVERY ONE
WILL HAVE A CONNECTION TO THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
>> ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT’S
OUT THERE POLITICO IS REPORTING
TONIGHT THAT STEVE BANNON MAY
HAVE BEEN PICKED UP ON SOME OF
THESE SURVEILLANCES.
HOW DOES THAT STRIKE YOU?
RIGHT IN THE HEART OF THE
CAMPAIGN AND THEY’VE ALSO GOT
NOW STEVE BANNON ACCORDING TO
POLITICO THAT THEY WERE SPYING
ON AS WELL?
>> JASON, WE KNOW TWO THINGS
RIGHT NOW DESPITE THAT
INTERESTING LITTLE OPENING BY
LEO THERE.
WE KNOW THAT THE OBAMA TEAM
SPIED ON THE TRUMP TEAM.
THAT’S NOT IN DISPUTE.
HOW IT HAPPENED MAY BE IN
DISPUTE.
WE KNOW THAT HAPPENED.
WHAT WE ALSO KNOW IS WE KNOW
BECAUSE THERE ARE COURT
TRANSCRIPTS, OKAY?
THERE IS AN ACTUAL RECORD OF
THIS THAT NO DEMOCRAT CAN RUN
FROM AND NO DEMOCRAT WILL HAVE
PLAUSIBLE DENYABILITY ON.
THE BULK OF THE MATERIAL THAT
WENT IN FRONT OF THE FISA COURT
JUDGES WAS PROVIDED BY, IN
FACT, THE DOSSIER, A DOSSIER
THAT CAME FROM TWO SOURCES,
RUSSIANS WHO PASSED IT THROUGH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, AND CLINTON
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATES.
ALL THE DEMOCRAT MEMOS IN THE
WORLD AREN’T GOING TO CHANGE
THOSE TWO SIMPLE FACTS.
FULL STOP.
>> THAT’S CLASSIC TALKING
POINTS, DAN.
F.B.I. GETS THEIR INFORMATION
FROM ALL DIFFERENT SOURCES.
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS.
>> NO, NO, NO THAT’S NOT RIGHT.
>> COME ON NOW.
LET ME GET A PAGE OUT OF
JASON’S BOOK.
TREY GOWDY, YOU KNOW HIM, HE
SAID THERE IS A NEED TO PROCEED
WITH THE RUSSIAN PROBE.
YOU DON’T DISAGREE WITH TREY
GOWDY, DO YOU DAN?
>> WE’RE TALKING ABOUT THE
CREDIBILITY -- SURVEILLING
PEOPLE THAT NOW HAS EXPANDED TO
INCLUDE POTENTIALLY AT LEAST
WE’RE LOOKING AT A REPORT
THAT’S PUT OUT BY POLITICO
TONIGHT THAT INCLUDES STEVE
BANNON.
THAT DOES BEG THE QUESTION WHO
ELSE -- LET ME GO TO JOHN FOR A
SECOND.
JOHN, WHERE DO YOU SEE THIS
GOING IN THE NEXT WEEK OR TWO?
>> I THINK THE LAST PIECE OF
THE EVIDENCE THAT CAME IN THAT
SUBSTANTIATEED THE FISA WARRANT
CAME FROM THE AUSTRALIAN
AMBASSADOR WHO HEARS
PAPADOPOULOS IN THE BAR DRUNK
AND HAVING CONVERSATION WITH
HIM.
I THINK WE’LL LEARN ABOUT THAT
AMBASSADOR AND HIS LOYALTIES.
I THINK YOU’LL FIND OUT FOUR
OUT OF FOUR THINGS THE F.B.I.
USED TO START LISTENING ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN COMES BACK TO
THE CLINTON FAMILY.
>> LEO, DOES ANY OF THIS --
DOES ANY OF THIS CONCERN YOU?
AND I HAVE TO ASK YOU GIVE --
LOOK RIGHT IN THE CAM RAND TELL
US, IF DONALD TRUMP HAD DONE
THIS AGAINST A DEMOCRAT, YOU
CAN’T TELL ME THAT YOU WOULD
JUST BE SITTING IDLY BY SAYING
THE F.B.I. JUST ACTED PERFECTLY
IN THIS INSTANCE.
>> I’M LOOKING YOU AND THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC NOW AND LEANING
FORWARD.
DONALD TRUMP IS BASICALLY
ATTACKING EVERY INSTITUTION IN
THE AMERICAN GOVERNMENT THAT HE
CONTROLS.
THE CIA, F.B.I., DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
YOU WANT ME TO DRINK THAT
KOOL-AID AND BELIEVE THE ENTIRE
GOVERNMENTAL SECURITY AGENCIES
ARE AGAINST DONALD TRUMP?
YOU WANT ME TO DRINK THAT
KOOL-AID TODAY ON NATIONAL
TODAY?
DO YOU BELIEVE THE ENTIRE
SECRET SERVICE AND THE F.B.I.
AND DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
EVERYONE?
COME ON.
>> LEO, IT’S AMAZING.
YOU DO THIS -- LIBERALS DO THIS
ALL THE TIME.
THEY NEVER ADDRESS WHAT YOU SAY.
THEY GO ON TO SOMETHING ELSE.
HE NEVER ADDRESSED AT ALL THE
SUBSTANCE OF WHAT I SAID.
WE KNOW FOR A FACT THE OBAMA
TEAM SPIED ON THE TRUMP TEAM.
WE KNOW THE INFORMATION WAS
PROVIDED BY STEELE THROUGH THE
RUSSIANS AND KNOW THE
INFORMATION WAS PROVIDED
THROUGH CLINTON -- I KNOW
BECAUSE ONE OF THEM WROTE AN
OP-ED IN THE "WASHINGTON POST"
ADMITTING TO IT AND ANOTHER ONE
WENT ON A WEEKEND NEWS SHOW AND
ADMITTED TO IT, TOO.
GO ON ABOUT THE RUSSIANS AGAIN.
THAT’S WHAT THEY DO.
>> I’LL PLAY YOUR GAME.
THEREFORE, WHAT?
WHAT ARE YOU MAKING CONCLUSION?
TELL US YOUR CONCLUSION.
THEREFORE WHAT?
WHO CAN --
>> THEREFORE THE OBAMA TEAM --
YOU MAY BE HARD OF HEARING BUT
I ALREADY SAID IT.
THE OBAMA TEAM SPIED ON THE
TRUMP TEAM.
THERE IS STILL NO PROBABLE
CAUSE THAT ANYONE ON THE TRUMP
TEAM WAS A FOREIGN AGENT IN
VIOLATION OF US LAW.
NO ONE PRODUCED ANY EVIDENCE OF
RUGS COLLUSION AND ARE YOU
STICKING BY IT WAS ALL DONE
BECAUSE YOU’RE A POLICE STATE
SUPPORTER, END OF STORY.
>> HOLD ON.
LET ME GO TO JOHN HERE.
THERE ARE STILL A MOUNTAIN OF
TEXT MESSAGES THAT WE HAVE NOT
SEEN.
>> TRUE.
>> IS THERE ANY FALLOUT YOU’RE
SEEING?
THE F.B.I. PUT OUT THERE THEY
COULDN’T FIND THE MISSING TEXT
MESSAGES.
>>
>> THEY SHOWED UP.
>> THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND
THEM.
I THINK HIS REPORT WILL HELP TO
RESOLVE HOW MUCH POLITICS WAS
INVOLVED AND HOW MUCH
LEGITIMATE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHEN WE SEE WHAT THE
INDEPENDENT I.G. FINDS AND THE
DEBATE WILL TAKE A DIFFERENT
TACT.
>> HE IS MAKING THIS PREDICTION
ABOUT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORT.
PLEASE HAVE ME ON WHEN THIS
REPORT COMES OUT?
I HOPE ACCORDING TO DAN THERE
WILL BE ALL THE INDICTMENTS
AGAINST THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
IT IS DOOM.
A GREAT WAY TO DEFLECT FROM
DONALD TRUMP AND THE RUSSIAN
PROBE.
GREAT MOVE, DAN.
VERY SMART.
>> LEO, WE HAVE 15 SECONDS.
WHAT IS YOUR SINGLE BEST PIECE
OF EVIDENCE THAT DONALD TRUMP
COLLUDED WITH RUSSIANS.
>> THE TREY GOWDY APPROACH.
A COUPLE RUSSIANS WERE MEETING
AT TRUMP TOWER.
I WILL USE THE SAME ONE.
TRUMP MEETING WITH THE RUSSIANS
AT TRUMP TOWER, PRETTY SOLID
EVIDENCE THERE.
>> YOU GET THE LAST WORD, DAN.
WHERE DO YOU SEE THIS GOING?
>> GENIUS CASE THERE.
MAYBE MARK WARNER SHOULD BE
UNDER ARREST FOR TRYING TO SET
UP A MEETING WITH THE RUSSIANS.
THE DEMOCRAT SENATOR FROM
VIRGINIA.
UNBELIEVABLE.
HE HAS NOTHING.
>> THE ONE THING I THINK WE CAN
ALL AGREE ABOUT WE’LL TALK